Bio diversity or biological diversity
is a term that refers to the number of genes, species,
individual organisms within a given species
and biological communities within a defined geographic area
ranging from the smallest ecosystem to the global biosphere.
Likewise, biodiversity loss describes the decline in the number,
genetic variability and variety of species.
This loss in the variety of life
can lead to a breakdown in the functioning of the ecosystem.
Where decline has happened.
Earth staggering biodiversity is in a state of crisis.
Species are disappearing faster than ever in human history.
Globally, at least
1.2 million plant
and animal species are estimated to be under threat of extinction,
many of them before 21.
Some of the most threatened groups include amphibians,
psychads and corals. Since the 16th century,
at least 680 vertebrates
and almost 600 plant species are documented to have gone extinct.
Currently, species are disappearing
10 to 1 thousand times faster than the normal
background rate of extinction.
All this suggests that we have entered the sixth mass extinction event,
the first in Earth's history to be driven primarily by human activity.
Extinctions are always preceded by declining populations
and contractions in a species range.
The Worldwide Fund for Nature's Living Planet Report 2022
documents a 69% average loss in the abundance of mammal, bird,
reptile, fish and amphibian species since 1970.
The populations of vertebrates
living in freshwater ecosystems have declined even more
by 83% on average over the same period.
Biodiversity loss is caused By five primary drivers.
In each case, human beings and their activities play direct roles.
Habitat loss is the thinning,
fragmenting or outright destruction of an ecosystem's plant, soil,
hydrologic and nutrient resources.
An invasive species is any non
native species that significantly modifies
or disrupts the ecosystems it colonizes.
Invasive species can disrupt ecosystems
because they are better competitors than native species.
Over exploitation, also known as over hunting
and over fishing
is the process of harvesting too many aquatic or terrestrial animals
which depletes the stocks of some species
while driving others to extinction.
Polution is the addition of unneeded
or harmful nutrients or substances to an ecosystem.
Global warming
is the long term increase in Earth's average air temperature,
which has occurred largely from human activities
over the past one to two centuries.
Preventing biodiversity loss is crucial for the health of ecosystems
and the well being of all living organisms,
including humans. By taking action
and adopting a holistic approach to biodiversity conservation,
we can work towards preventing further biodiversity loss
and ensuring the long term
health and resilience of ecosystems worldwide.